this is where the the really intense
podcast gets really really intense
it's called the forbidden question the
forbidden question
is are we living in what is called a
base reality or are we living in a
virtual
reality or a simulated reality that is
reflecting
a base reality somewhere else now a lot
of people think you know well this is
science fiction
if consciousness informs itself through
its creations and we have made
all of these movies about these
simulations
what are we asking ourselves to remember
2001 the first scientific experiments
were run
and a paper was written by a man named
nick bostrom but he asked the question
he said are we living in in a virtual
reality
he set up a very complex algorithm and
ran the algorithm on the computer and
the bottom line
is that the odds are greater that we are
in a simulation
than that we are not in the simulation
this podcast exists because i
love talking to people and i love going
deep the purpose
is to plant seeds of inspiration we
enter a space of vulnerability and
relatability and what you realize is
that we
are so much more alike than we are
different to quote ramdas
we're all just walking each other home
and this show
is just one step i'm danica patrick and
i'm pretty intense
it is my great honor to welcome to the
show today
greg braden i'm a huge fan of greg
braden
i'd call him kind of part of this like
cool brat pack that are like
leading edge scientists and doctors and
geologists and archaeologists and uh
all all the ologists uh with joe
dispenza
with nasim haramine with bruce lipton
greg braden is a five-time new york
times best-selling author
scientist international educator and
renowned as a pioneer in the emerging
paradigm based in science
social policy and human potential
and what a better time to talk to
somebody about human potential than
right
now which was the basis of our
conversation there are so many different
directions that
um can be gone with greg uh he's uh
so well qualified in so many different
aspects of uh things that
i'm for sure curious about uh but today
we focused on
uh you know human potential we talked
about what are we like what is our
nature uh
we talked about the difference between
science and spirituality and how they
merge and uh it was all just about
the human condition the human experience
and what we're here for and where we
could be going so fascinating
conversation
and i was most excited to hear that he
was totally down for a part two on other
things and
i hope you love him as much as i do
because i'm probably gonna ask for that
so enjoy
hey danica you're my neighbor i didn't
know that you're my neighbor in arizona
i'm
i am in a studio just outside of santa
fe in new mexico today oh man we are
neighbors
is that where you live all the time it's
in santa fe uh
my uh i have a home i i bought in 1986
up north of taos it literally is in the
middle of nowhere
so i have that home and i used to fly
uh out of the albuquerque airport every
week so this gets
gets me closer to the airport and this
was a good place to be for covid
uh it was much more much more functional
for
i have better internet access here so i
could do uh all the things that i did
during covid
where are you from i was born i'm a
midwestern boy i was born in
missouri and you're you're just north of
me i think is where you were that's
right a little east yeah i'm from
illinois
i was born in wisconsin but grew up in
illinois um
so i i mean good midwesterners like you
always know when you've met one because
they're very friendly
very kind they're really outgoing
they're just you know
we're good we're good people yeah
and and i gotta tell you it was a good
place to be with muscle cars back in in
the day the midwest is where it was at i
got to tell you
it's probably what got my dad there
which ended up getting me there
um so totally true totally true
i want to talk about everything but we
don't have time for everything
so i had to break it down i i think
where i'd like to go with this
is really understanding what we are
where we came from what we are the
nature of our
existence and then you know how that
relates to
where we're going or where we could go
with artificial intelligence and you
know the potential of humans versus
maybe
what's natural versus what's not
and or or is that i mean kind of
unpacking all that
um i would love to get into geology and
into artifacts and into
ancient you know ruins and
things found and you know i was just
watching
something the other day one of something
i'd record i had
downloaded a whole bunch of stuff on
youtube uh from
your youtube and anyway one of them
showed you know
skulls that were the elongated skulls
which are very common people have seen
and it's like
how can we not how do we see elongated
skulls and not just go
we don't know all there is to know about
our history
anyway i digress geologies for another
day
i think that was a very relevant topic
right now is
empowerment sovereignty what we are
and where we're going so one of the
things that you say so many times
is that we're advanced beings that have
uh a self-regulatory system
and so you know what when you say that
we're an advanced being
explain that and in relation to what
you know we just covered a lot of ground
you just asked a lot of questions and
the truth is
that they're all related and there can
be no digression
because we are holistic beings living in
a holistic universe
part of all that is and that is the
fallacy for the way that we
we try to approach so many of our
problems the fallacy that we
are somehow separate from one another
separate from our world
uh and powerless victims of our
environment and i think one of the
things that's happening right now danica
the
if you know if you're going to have a
global pandemic it's good to have it
in the age of the internet because the
internet has allowed us to stay
connected and it's allowed us to access
information in ways that we we never
have in the past
and part of that access i think is the
answer to to the question
that you just asked so i'm going to
begin the answer by simply
saying there's a battle that is
unfolding in our world
right now on multiple levels right in
front of our eyes we all know there's a
battle for our thoughts
that's very obvious the media is
battling
to inform and guide the way that we
think about ourselves and our
relationship to the world and how we
respond
to the pandemic and the economy and uh
race
and all the other things that are up for
us right now there's that battle
but that battle is based upon a battle
for our beliefs
and that battle is playing out in
academia it's playing out with what we
teach our kids
about who they are and the way that they
solve the problems of the world that
come to them from
from the time that they're very young
the battle for our beliefs
uh where did we come from are we an
accident
of lucky biology or is there some
intentionality
underlying our existence i mean that's a
huge question
is the universe dead and unconscious and
inert
or is the universe alive and intelligent
and connected
uh that battle is playing out there's a
battle for our bodies and i think we're
all getting that what does it take to
get healthy what's it take to stay
healthy what do we have to give our
our babies within moments of when they
emerge from the womb when they come into
this world
we are conditioned to think that they
have to have something
outside of themselves in order to
survive
all those battles are playing out but i
want to tell you they're all static
they're noise and they're covering what
i believe is the deepest battle of our
time
danica it's a battle for our very
humanness our
very humanness is on the line right now
because for the first time in recorded
human history we have the technology
that can steal our humanness from us
in ways that some people aren't even
aware of and other
societies and cultures are adopting
very very quickly and i'm talking about
computer chips implanted into the human
brain and
chemicals injected into the body and
wires
under the skin and the problem the
problem
with this technology that's moving so
fast
is that when we give our natural
humanness away when we give away our
biological potential
to technology our body begins to atrophy
with respect to those potentials so if
we're implanting chips in our brain our
neurons
we've all heard this before use it or
lose it biology you hear this all the
time
our neurons begin to think they're not
needed anymore
and so they stop producing in one
generation the next generation
they become uh an appendage of something
that used to be
we're not using them anymore and for the
first time
in 5 000 years of recorded human history
the technology
has the power to forever change our
species
and the question and this i'm laying the
foundation to answer the question that
you asked
the question is and i would never tell
anyone or try to convince or persuade
anyone
to or not to use the technology but
here's the key
the key is how much of ourselves do we
want to give away
to the technology and lose forever we
can't answer that until we know who we
are and that brings us back
to the very first question that you
asked and it i gotta tell you it's where
the scientific discoveries are coming so
fast and furious
uh in these obscure technical journals
that very few people get to see but
they're based upon peer-reviewed science
and they're writing a new human story
and that new human story
is what the covid pandemic is pushing us
to understand
so i'm going to stop right there and ask
does that make sense first of all yeah
of course it does yeah so the
i think one of the things uh that we're
beginning to understand
we we have been conditioned for a couple
of generations now
to see the human body is a flawed
organism
carbon-based life in general and the
human body specifically
is somehow flawed and
because of this flood that we need to
build
things outside of us that will help us
to become the best versions of ourselves
to become
the achieve our greatest potentials
whether it's athletics or whether it's
mental or emotional capabilities all of
these things
so this is the path that that technology
is following very very quickly and what
we're seeing
is that the technology has advanced
faster
than the morality of how we apply it in
our lives i just give you a perfect
example what i mean by that
a couple of years ago scientific papers
began
describing the ability to edit
the dna uh of an in of a fetus
inside the womb of a living woman just
the way you would edit
uh a document in a word processor on the
computer
so on the word processor you can you can
add or delete words you can highlight
the entire paragraph
cut it paste it somewhere else we now
have editors
where the the genes come up on the
computer screen and you can highlight
and delete and merge and remove
and rearrange genes in the dna of a
living organism
to optimize and perfect that organism
while it's still in the womb before it's
ever born and the question is
whose idea of what is optimum
do we begin to use to do something like
that well well this was all
theory they were doing it in the lab
until 2018.
in 2018 there's a chinese scientist that
very proudly said
holding the baby in his arms here are
our first
gene edited human babies he had done
in real life what had been done in the
laboratory in theory and then tests and
the scientific community came down on
him like a ton of bricks
because they said wait a minute just
because we can
doesn't mean that we should and we see
this time
and time again with technology where the
technology
advances just because we can implant
a computer chip into the human brain
that
connects us with a hard drive of our
computer with no wires
no keyboards and allows us to download
information does that mean that we
should
and we cannot answer those things danica
until we begin
to understand who we are so these
discover this is the way science works
the discoveries are pushing science
to understand who we are and what they
are discovering
is a mind blower because what they're
i'll just say it and then
we can unpack it what they're
discovering
i'm going to say it like this we have
yet
to discover any technology
built outside of the human body that
does
not mimic what we already do in the
cells
and the neurons and the organs of our
body except we do it better
we are what is called a soft technology
so rather than thinking of a hard
computer chip
in wires and chemicals we're talking
about
neurons and and fluids ion potentials
moving across the membranes of cell
walls and crystalline bone
structure and when we begin to
understand what that means
and the ability our innate ability to
self-regulate
this technology that's the mind blower
because
what it says is that yeah we we can do
these things
in the technology but the technology
maybe is reminding us of who we are
to push us in that evolutionary
direction
and uh and there's so much that i can i
can go into about that but i
i and i want to but i'm just going to
take a breath and
and see if there are questions or yeah
you're okay with where this is going
beautiful i i mean what comes up for me
is and this is sort of a question i keep
asking of
you know the nature of reality and other
people around me at
a pure curiosity and and um and
uh dialogue but you know there's such a
fascination around
are we a simulation are we not and
there's just so many
ways to see there's an argument on both
sides
i feel and you know when we talk about
being able to
you know upgrade and pattern
and all kinds of things you think about
well it seems like we're some kind
of a program in and of ourselves and so
is uh technology natural
because we are too or is
uh is it completely outside of us
meaning we are
biological sort of autonomous beings
with
uh you know a spirit having a human
experience
um it's really like that whole dynamic
is so
i like wrap my head around different
concepts about that all the time
what are your thoughts on on just the
idea of being a simulation
can you even vet that out to truth oh
yeah
absolutely so you know i'm going to
begin this is um well i love this
conversation
already this is i'm i'm going to begin
with a story
uh because the story lays a beautiful
fabric
that we can tie into i mentioned i'm
i'm living in the high desert in
northern new mexico
uh where there are a lot of indigenous
pueblos and archaeological sites
and it was in the early 90s that i was
hiking through one of the archaeological
sites in the four corners area it's
chaco canyon some people maybe you've
been there some people know where that
is
and i uh an indigenous man uh
was was coming the other direction he
stopped and talked to me on
on the path and he began telling me a
story
uh it was really interesting and he said
a long time ago
people in this part of the world lived
very differently they were close to the
earth they remembered who they were
they remembered their relationship to
the earth
to the sky to the past to the future to
time
he said then something happened and we
don't know exactly
what the something was but people got
lost
something happened and they began to
forget who they were
and they so longed for the connection
that they used to have with themselves
with one another
and with the earth and with the
ancestors they began
building things outside of their bodies
to remind them of who they are inside of
their bodies and he said we live in that
world today
we are still cluttering our outer world
with all of this technology and
everything that we're building
out there in some way
mirrors mimics what we already do in
here and he said we're going to keep
doing this we will
clutter our world and clutter our lives
until
we come to this realization he said and
then we will let that external
technology go
so the life and the world looks simpler
but we have become
much more sophisticated and much more
evolved beings and i thought
wow you know i thought i was just on a
hike in chaco canyon and that
that was a very very deep philosophy
well i'm i'm a scientist
i'm a degree earth scientist with a
strong background in
uh in life sciences biological sciences
and math physics and computer science
and i say that because it helps me to
stay current danica with all of the
research
that's not always easy to read it's it's
published in very obscure journals
very technical language and you know
life is simple nature is simple science
is simple
until we make it complex with with his
language and with
the formulas and and the math if you
want to engineer it you need those
things but to understand it you do not
so i have the opportunity to
to stay current with the discoveries and
all the new discoveries are confirming
what that native man
said to me that that we are
we are literally a soft technology so
let me
share what that means and i'm going to
tie that into the answer about the
simulation
the average human body we're told has
about 50 trillion or so
cells you know give or take when i was
in school
back in 1950s 60s early 70s i was taught
that those cells were like little sacks
of
of salt water you know saline you know
there's some other stuff going on but
nothing like what we know today now we
know
that every one of those 50 trillion
cells has
about .07 volts of electrical potential
and you say well you know that's that's
not very much and you're right but you
do the math
50 trillion cells times .07 volts i've
done this so many times i'll tell you
is 3.5 trillion volts of electrical
potential
now if you could harness that and direct
that
to states of healing or intuition
or or or extraordinary states of
cognition
or resilience or building a powerful
immune system man who doesn't want that
you know in the age of covet
but it doesn't stop there because every
one of those cells
also is functions and essentially is in
our body it's a capacitor
it's a resistor it's a transistor these
these are all electrical components that
massage electrical information
every cell in our body receives photons
of light that is information and energy
and
we not only receive it we transmit we
are constantly
transmitting photons of light into this
field that we haven't talked about yet
that underlies all existence we are in
direct
communication it's a conversation it's a
two-way conversation
with this field every cell in our body
the surface of our
because of covid everybody knows of what
a cell looks like now
and about the receptors on the cells
those receptors are antenna
and they are constantly receiving light
information
and electrical and magnetic information
the dna
in the nucleus of our cells our antenna
essentially the genes that make up the
dna
our antennae the higher frequencies we
are
gated circuits all of this is a very
very different way of looking at the
human body and and this is
where we go back to the first part of
this conversation we are the only form
of life danica
that we know of today maybe others
elsewhere in the cosmos i'm sure there
are but we're the only form of life on
earth
that has the ability to self-regulate
all of this soft technology
and to do it consciously at will and on
demand
other forms of life may do it by
instinct we're the only form of life it
can sit down in a chair in a moment in
time
and say in this moment i choose to
access this
this soft technology within me and
create a stronger immune system or
awaken my my anti-aging uh and longevity
enzymes you know who doesn't want that
we're the only form of life that can do
this we are
technology we are a soft technology
interfacing with a field of energy and
information
that modern science is only beginning to
acknowledge
so we begin to think from that
perspective now i'm going to go back
there's an emerging
philosophy that everything that we
create
that consciousness consciousness
informs itself through its creations
so that means everything that we create
in the world
out there is telling us something about
ourselves in here and this it's a it's a
mind blower it's a really interesting
way of thinking so all the art
all the sculptures all the music i'm a
musician when i'm
when i'm not being an author all the
music that we create
uh the movies hollywood look at the
films that people are most drawn true to
the blockbusters
and and look at the themes of those
films the matrix for example
told us that there's a world that we
can't see that we participate in
that influences a world that we can see
the movie avatar
reminded us of our relationship to to
nature in the natural world
inception was all about dreams and
dreams within
dreams and the young people i love this
young people are so turned on man they
are fired up over the superheroes the
avengers and wonder woman
all reminding them that there is a
potential within them
that maybe they have yet to fully tap
that we have abilities that we're only
beginning to understand so
if consciousness informs itself
through its creations then that
principle would extend to the technology
so i am not surprised that the internet
that we built mimics our neural networks
within our bodies
yeah i'm not surprised that blockchain
technology that is revolutionizing
finance and and what
money even means in the world and
bringing
peace to nations because they don't have
to
compete for natural resources for the
old kinds of money we used to think
about
i'm not supply surprise that blockchain
technology
mimics human dna in a blockchain
technology
there is a record of every transaction
that has ever occurred from the very
first transaction in
our genome is a record of every genetic
transaction that has ever transpired
from the time that we first emerged on
this planet
so this is such a powerful principle
consciousness
informs itself through its creations
so if this is true now we
are using technology to build
simulations
and we've only had computers danica you
know i mean really high-speed computers
we've had them for maybe 40 years
and look at where we are now we are
creating simulations that are almost
indistinguishable from everyday life
so the question now that scientists are
asking
uh this is where the the really intense
podcast gets really really intense
it's called the forbidden question the
forbidden question
is are we living in what is called a
base reality or are we living in a
virtual
reality or a simulated reality that is
reflecting
a base reality somewhere else now a lot
of people think you know well this is
science fiction
if consciousness informs itself through
its creations and we have made
all of these movies about these
simulations
what are we asking ourselves to remember
so where this really took a turn i mean
it's interesting you know
conversation at starbucks uh until 2001
2001 the first scientific experiments
were run
uh and a paper was written by a man
named nick bostrom and maybe you've
you've had him on the program or other
people have referenced him i don't know
but he asked the question he said are we
living in
in a virtual reality and he he set up a
very complex algorithm
and ran the algorithm on the computer
and the bottom line
is that the odds are greater that we are
in a simulation
than that we are not in the simulation
so that that was 2001 2014
this went further and they began
a series of of physics experiments
regarding reality and this is one of the
first as you were covering all of the
ground you know what is our relationship
to reality
and the bottom line to these experiments
is what they found is that our
physical reality only exists
when something is observing it
and this this ties back to experiments
that were done early in the the 20th
century
called the double slit very famous
double slit experiments
that atoms or quantum particles
will behave one way when they're not
being observed
and they will behave another way when
they are when they're not being observed
they're waves that you can't see
when they are observed through a camera
or a recording mechanism or human
consciousness
then those waves collapse into particles
that become
our reality where this gets really
interesting
is this is precisely the way we build
our simulations today
our computers can't hold if if you're
going to have a simulation
of a jungle your computer cannot
hold all of the information to make
every leaf
and all the bark on all the trees and
all the insects and the rocks and the
water
in that jungle and just hold it there
when when it's not being used
so the computer doesn't do that the
computer only puts those there
when that part of the simulation is
going to be used
the experiments strongly suggest that
our reality
works in a very very similar fashion and
that we
are the odds are greater that we are
than that we are not living in some kind
of a
a simulation or a uh a simulated reality
or a virtual reality
before just before he died uh stephen
hawking this was
his great i've got a beautiful recording
of him
say stating this he said the the
question you know he solved all these
mysteries
black holes and you know where's the
edge of the universe and how big is the
universe and he said the greatest
question
he said we must determine once and for
all if we are in fact living in a base
reality
and if we're not living in a base
reality what does that mean
so for me this is this is exciting and
it opens the door
to a lot of possibilities first of all
it doesn't change our everyday lives
we're here we're in it
but you think about this danica the
purpose of a simulation
is to learn something in a relatively
safe environment
where you can make mistakes
learn something that you're going to
need when you get to another
environment that may not be so safe and
so
so here's where the scientists are right
now then i'll stop and we can
we can maybe unpack where all this is if
the odds are greater
that we are living in a simulation
why and who would have created it
and this is this is where the scientific
community is right now if we can create
the kinds of simulations that we have
now after only 40 years of computers
what if we you and me and everybody
watching this
what if we are all part of a highly
advanced society
that has had computers for thousands of
years
and we're living in a world where we've
run up against a problem that we're
trying to solve
and we're using the simulations to try
to solve those problems
and you say what would those problems be
i don't know
but you look at the theme of what plays
out in our world today there's
there's a constant theme of good versus
bad you know
dark versus light there's a constant
theme of our relationship
to the environment maybe we're on a
planet where the environment's going to
collapse
and we're trying to figure out what to
do about that or maybe maybe we're on
in a world where we've been ravaged by
disease and war
and we're looking for another way and
and if we are in a simulation why would
you stop with only one simulation
it makes sense that you would run many
simulations to try to find the best
answer and
physicists say this is the mini world's
theory or the multiple universe or the
parallel
universe theory so all of this
is uh is really coming to a focus in the
scientific community
because we've pushed technology so far
we understand the compartmentalized
aspects but now we're trying to put it
all together to make sense of our world
and this is where science
and scientists are finding themselves
and it's rocking
a lot of boats it's blowing a lot of
minds and it opens the door to a lot of
possibilities
of hope peace it gives new meaning
to spirituality if we're in a simulation
and you're communicating with your
higher self is that you
outside the simulation is that you and
in that base reality
or when you're talking to you know your
deceased
ancestors uh are are they on the other
side of that veil
helping you in in that simulation which
is just what we would
if you're in a flight a cockpit flight
simulator for example we're all familiar
with those
you're in you're in the simulation but
you always have
access to information outside that
simulation to help you through
and there are rules in that simulation
that will help you
that will make your your simulation
easier that will make life easier
and the simulations always have a
beginning and they always have an
end and we look at our most ancient and
cherished spiritual traditions they all
say the same thing
they say this is the illusion this is
the maya this isn't real it's a dream
we have a beginning we have an end we're
here to learn something
so i think the idea that you have
so skillfully brought into this
conversation is
becoming the bridge between
the best science of the modern world and
our most ancient and cherished spiritual
traditions
but it's all coming together danica in a
way that is real and practical
because we're up against it right now
there's a battle for our humanness
what does it mean to be human and maybe
what we're learning is how to assume
this extraordinary potential
that comes with a human body and we do
it we do it through life we do it
through marriages and divorces and
relationships and
and disease and joy and
rock and roll and muscle cars
from my age back in the 60s and 70s
and i think there's a way to do it and
and enjoy ourselves while we're doing it
and i think that's
that joy is really what sparks a lot of
this potential in our lives so i'm going
to take a breath
right there we just covered a lot of
ground and i'll ask you
if it makes sense or where you want to
go with that of course of course of
course
uh it does make sense and so many
questions come up and
so many curiosities and we can literally
take what you said and branch off into
all kinds of different directions
off of them but the last thing to come
up was
in my mind was um if we like i'm
like vetting out more of the spiritual
side of things and
um you know theorizing that there was an
original energy in the universe the
sophia energy and that it comes down and
and and it fractions off so it can know
itself
and so if we look at it from that
spiritual perspective
i feel like that also could make sense
too trying to experience itself
information and informing us our
are we i've been thinking about this a
lot how
being a human is actually fairly simple
and that uh everything in our reality is
really
giving us information about ourself
whether it's through triggers or
projections or
how someone treats you it's all
information about the self and so
that could be that spirit that source
energy
god whatever you want to call it sophia
energy original energy
experiencing itself learning about
itself
so what are your thoughts on it being
more from a spiritual perspective
yeah you know i think the line between
uh spirituality
and science and everyday life gets
really fuzzy
when when we begin where do you well
honestly where do you draw the line
between everyday life and spirituality
where do you draw the line between light
and dark
in the moment i'll just tell you the
moment you draw that line you've fallen
into the ancient trap that keeps us
stuck
and spinning in the false boundaries
that we in the past have locked
ourselves into
i have friends in the spiritual
community that say i only hang out with
people of the light i only hang out with
spiritual people
and i say you know that's cool where do
you draw the line
between the people that are spiritual
and the ones that are not and the moment
you do that you're in judgment
and that judgment is what keeps you
locked into your deepest fears
and it limits it limits your heart
in the world because we we are all we've
heard this we're all
more than than the worst thing we've
ever done every one of us is
and we're all learning you know we're
all learning we're on this
this very steep learning curve that i
think has just gotten steeper
and the technology is forcing the
learning curve
because we've got to come to terms with
who we are
and what it means to be human to know
how to answer the questions of what
technology do we bring
do we bring into our lives you know
there are places where
the technology is it's already
changing what it means to be human
there are some societies i'll tell you
japan the japanese culture is as a
beautiful example they've always been
very open to embracing technology and
they've always been on the forefront
in some ways they're like the canary in
in the coal mine
because they have gone places now that
we can
we can look and say do we want to go
there one of
the examples of that and the scientific
papers that are
are describing this is that they are
replacing
intimate human relationships with
digital relationships because they're
easier
they're cleaner you don't have to get
tied up in
messy conversations you don't have to
get tied up
in arguments and disagreements so
they are relationships that are
happening online
uh including sexual relationships that
are happening online
well what's remember use it or lose it
one of the things they're finding in
japanese culture
is that women are losing their ability
to conceive sperm counts are dropping in
men and the birth rate is now
dropped below the mortality rate people
are dying faster than
than babies are being born and it's not
a hundred percent
because of the technology but the
technology and the lifestyle have
contributed
to these to these things is that where
we want to go do we
and there is a movement i mean we could
have a conversation about this
that is called the transhuman movement
that firmly believes uh that
human carbon-based life and humans are
flawed
that sexuality is a distraction it's a
diversion that we don't need it and they
want to wean us
from that so that we're more efficient
beings
and this is where a lot of this
technology is is going in
and wean us away they believe that
emotion is our flaw
and so as we become less
emotional beings we become more
efficient and better able to solve
problems
that's their their thinking i'm pushing
back strongly on that
it is it's the power of human emotion
that gives us the ability to
self-regulate
regenerate rejuvenate our biology in a
way that no other form of life
can so that we we awaken this soft
technology and hopefully
like i said have a lot of fun doing it i
mean once
the better you know yourself the less
you fear
change in the world because
when we don't know who we are and
we our sense of well-being hinges upon
that external world
as long as the world is good man we're
cool but the minute that world starts to
change like
right now these days people are
just going nuts because they've lost
that sense of well-being they can't you
can't hinge your
well-being on a moving target and the
world is changing
and it's not finished the world is
changing so quickly
they don't know who they are and the way
that people
typically will respond to that
uncertainty is through fear
and the fear often is expressed is hate
so we are seeing hate emerging in this
changing world because people
have forgotten who they are so the
better the better we know ourselves and
this is
this is where the science becomes very
applicable in our everyday lives you'd
have to know
the math or the technology and don't get
hung up in the words of simulation and
all that
bottom line is the better we know
ourselves
the better equipped we are to deal with
whatever life brings to our doorstep
the less we fear change in the world
around us the less we fear
one another but what's really important
is the better we know ourselves
the less we fear our own power and i
want to tell you what we're finding is
we are
such awesomely awesomely
powerful beings and i think you know
i've been with live audiences
uh all over the world the last 40 years
and people tell me all it's not just the
american thing or european thing all
over the world
people sense from the time that their
children that there is a power within
them
that they're afraid of they're afraid
they'll misuse it
uh it can be as simple as the power to
take
a life or the power to give a life
become even more complex than that so
the better we know
ourselves the more peaceful our world is
going to become
because we will need
the stability outside of us less we
become more
certain because of our uh of our our
inner
technology our inner stability and and i
think we're we're all finding that
you know the covet conversation is
pushing that the vaccine conversation
is pushing that we we've been
conditioned to believe that we are
powerless when it comes
to contagions in the world maybe some
people are maybe they're not
i'm glad that there's technology so that
we have alternatives and we can make
informed choices
but making an informed choice is very
different
than being frightened into feeling
powerless
and it's a subtle difference and it's a
very very powerful difference it's up
for everybody
right now it's a big point of
conversation for sure
it's a contentious point of conversation
um which is interesting right i mean
it's just
i feel as though things are being pulled
so
far in two directions to in my mind and
in my experience
uh to end up realizing that it's a
circle
and that we're all part of the same
whole in my own personal experience of
emotions and different things which
i hope to god we don't cancel emotions
because
as i broke open further and further into
pain i also broke further and further
open to joy and what i ended up
realizing is they're part of the same
hole which is me
exactly exactly you know danica i just
want to
in case we leave this and don't come
back to it i don't want to leave our
our viewers with a dangling conversation
you know hanging
what i see happening right now you know
we've laid out a lot of information
i think we are in the midst of
witnessing
two parallel societies that are emerging
at the same time and and it's not that
one part of that society is necessarily
another
other side of town it can be happening
at the family dinner table
where the parents are thinking one way
and i have friends that are involved in
this i have no children my own but i
have a lot of
most my friends have children and we
talk about this
parents think one way and the kids are
thinking another way two parallel
societies
are emerging and now that we're in it
the only way out of it is to go through
it
there was i think there there was a time
we could have circumvented a lot of the
suffering but
there wasn't a willingness to to really
embrace
where the world is and and the changes
that we're in we could have and we
didn't
for whatever reason i'm not right wrong
good or bad not judging it
so now that we're in it we've got to go
through it and
i think what we're learning is that we
can go through it with kindness
even though we may not all think the
same way
we're in it together we're all in the
same boat and
there is a way to differ with opinions
with with kindness
with compassion with understanding the
best science of the modern world
is now telling us that the fundamental
rule of nature is cooperation
it's not survival of the strongest as
darwin said
those are his exact words survival of
the strongest later they became survival
of the fittest
but his original words were survival the
strongest so what i think is happening
and i don't think it's going to take
long we cannot sustain this path
something's got to give
i don't think it's going to take very
long we're going to have two parallel
societies
once one one of those societies is going
to be all
in on everything they're going to be all
in on the technology
you know young kids saying hey man why
wouldn't i want to chip in my brain if i
can do my gaming
without a keyboard you know who wouldn't
want that
all in on surveillance all in on
whatever chemicals we need in our bodies
to protect us
from whatever we believe threatens us in
the world
all in on everything i'm seeing
something interesting happen
danica maybe you're seeing this in in
your your world as well
and this isn't even necessarily people
in the the spiritual realm what we call
spiritual or new thought or new age
it's just everyday people that are
saying wait a minute
something doesn't feel right we're
moving too fast
let's slow down let's go back to the
basics
let's go back to what does it mean
to have a family-centered life
what does it mean to simple things to
have dinner
you know with the kids and the parents
together what does it mean to grow some
of our own food in the backyard what
does it mean
rather than relying on chemicals outside
of us
maybe getting a little healthier inside
so that we don't need those chemicals
what does it mean to do that so these
are two very very different perspectives
but they're happening at the same time
so here's what's going to happen
we're going to check each other out
because that's what we do we're humans
we're going to check each other out and
we're going to say who is happier
who's healthier who is more fulfilled
in their life who has healthier
relationships
and whatever the answer to that is the
people that don't have it
are gonna want that it's like when harry
met sally i want what she's having
that's exactly right exactly and i think
this may be
what ultimately unifies us is
we will unify around shared
human values now i've got a lot of irons
and a lot of fires i'm uh
some of them are more public than others
uh i'm working with
an ngo uh regarding the
sustainable development goals at the un
the united nations
sustainable development goals they want
to implement by the year 2030.
the goals are beautiful if you read them
on the surface
if you look at what they are proposing
it takes to get to the goals it's
frightening so our group is pushing back
against
not the goals but the way that we're
going about implementing them
and my contribution to that is what i'm
saying to you right now
rather than trying to figure out the
best way to do
each of those goals it's like
whack-a-mole you know you you do
one thing here and another one there and
something else pops up
what my proposal is is that we must
arrive
together at a set of fundamental human
values
that we all cherish what what do we
cherish as individuals
what values do we cherish as a family as
a community as a society as a nation
as a planet and those
fundamental values if we can place those
at the foundation
of every policy that is enacted and
every law that's passed and every choice
that we make we cannot go wrong
if we honor these fundamental values
when we compromise those values for
economic gain
or for power or for control which we've
done in the past and
i say we not you and me but the powers
that be not our listeners but the powers
that be
when we do that we know what that world
looks like
so our world's changing we can't stop
the change we're either going to come in
for a crash landing or a soft landing
and my prayer is that we take this
opportunity that many
many are actually calling the great
reset that name it's on books it's on
magazine covers it's on cnn
it means different things of different
people but if
whatever that reset is as we embrace new
ways of thinking and living
my strong feeling is that we must
identify shared values
that we are not willing to compromise to
preserve
our humanness to preserve uh the
foundations
of of what biological life and what it
means to be human
and make those laws and policies conform
to those values and
i i think that is where the unity will
come from that
that will unify us because we will be
unified
in those values and you identified some
of these already the
the um sovereignty of the human body for
example
i think everyone feels that they
would like to have say on what happens
to their bodies in
in one form or another that's a very
powerful unifying
unifying experience i spent a lot of
time with indigenous traditions
in the last 40 years and i've seen this
principle work for them
where they may be tribes that don't get
along
but they all need water for example
so they would work together to
combine their resources to build one
well
to bring water waters life to bring
water to their villages and that one
well was the unifying principle that was
the shared value
it's a place to begin that brought them
together that they could build from
so i think our human values can become
the well
for our global family
to to take control and to say whatever
we don't know what the world's going to
look like but whatever that world is
if the world can honor these these
fundamental values
then then we're all on the same page and
i think that's that's
what we're going to see yes that makes
perfect sense that's a
great a perfect prayer to bring us
together
i'm curious what you think i mean you
know
again it's not necessarily science but
it's it's uh in the realm of
spirituality and if we're thinking
everything is a closed loop
somewhere somewhere they interm inter
they intersect
um but about a new earth concept and
you know uh what is that and what is
that concept and is that potentially
what it looks like when
we don't unify when we perhaps don't
uh learn the lesson in this uh
situation as uh humans go and
we there's a split there's a split
because i can feel that i feel exactly
what you're talking about the split
between people
um so what does that what does that look
like
you know the uh that split i think is
is what we're all feeling right now and
i'm you know i'm just gonna answer this
i'm a storyteller i i did an interview
uh last year at the end of the year
uh most interviews are pretty friendly
it was what
we in the business would call a hostile
interview i know you
you know what that means so it was uh it
was a commuter
uh a commuter uh early morning
commuter program i won't identify the
city but it's a really big city in the
northeast of america
really big city and the
the dj came on and he didn't he didn't
introduce me
didn't say welcome to the show good
morning how's the 6 a.m
my time none of that the first thing he
came
on uh he said when when he came on
he said greg braden why can't you stick
with one
topic like everybody else he says man
you're all over the map
he said what are you writing about are
you writing about the magnetic fields of
the earth or spirituality or human
biology or human potential
you know why can't you stay with one
topic like everyone else i thought he
was joking
and he wasn't took me back a little bit
and i said well i said
my work does cover a lot of ground but i
said if you look closely
every one of those books that you've
just referred to
identifies one facet
of our relationship to ourselves
and to the earth so in a very real sense
i have stayed with one topic it's just a
really big topic yeah
and he and he said okay let's go let's
let's go to break and he never came back
that was it was like the shortest
interview i've ever done
but that was the drop the mic yeah well
that was it but but the whole point
is from my perspective uh
i i draw a very powerful line between
spirituality and religion
from my perspective spirituality is
about relationships
it's about our relationship to the
planet to the earth to mother earth
pachamama gaia it's about our
relationship
to the cosmos it's about our
relationship to the universe
our relationship to one another to the
past to the future
probably most importantly our
relationship to ourselves
so these deeply spiritual principles
have existed almost from the time that
we have records of the first humans
spirituality religion came along later
and wrapped rules and dogma
around those spiritual principles and
led people to actually feel separate
from themselves
from the cosmos from a higher power from
the earth and powerless
needing some kind of external
intervention
so i'm i'm drawing that distinction i
i and i had to figure this out for
myself early in life i
am the product uh you may know this of a
very dysfunctional
abusive alcoholic family um you know in
the midwest
and i i learned i i
wanted to learn for myself and i wanted
to believe that i would not be defined
in my future life through my past
experiences
i didn't want those experiences to to
to limit who i would be and the only way
danica that i knew to do that was to
understand
myself my abilities my potential
uh and i was just a kid you know you do
it the way you know how to do it as a
kid
but those ideas followed me through life
and as i became a scientist they became
they became much much clearer
as a musician they became much clearer
music is such a powerful unifying force
and it's such a deeply emotive
force i didn't even talk about cymatics
but i love cymatics and i love
the idea of frequency and energy and how
emfs and you name it affect us but
absolutely yeah well sure well cymatics
came along in the 1990s
uh the gentleman that brought it to the
states i was good friends with him
he brought it out of uh out of europe uh
into the u.s his name was jeff volk i
hope jeff doesn't mind me
sharing his name uh and and these were
for
viewers that may not be familiar
cymatics is is the relatively new
science
of pumping vibration into
some kind of a physical matter can be a
liquid like water it can be very viscous
like mercury
it can be a fine powder like graphite or
sulfur or talcum whatever it is talcum
powder baby powder
but the point is that each vibration
creates
a pattern and every time that vibration
is repeated you get the same pattern and
it it was a way to help us to really
grasp this concept
that invisible forces have a physical
counterpart and and what is the role
of those non-physical forces thought is
a non-physical force
what is it doing in matter emotions are
a non-physical force
beliefs are a non-physical force
so uh as well as the magnetic fields of
the planet and
you know the the light coming in from
the universe and it opened the door to
to a lot of possibilities so
all of this to say that once again the
better
we know ourselves the better equipped we
are to deal with life in a healthy way
and this is the key you know we we'll
get through it but we want to get we
want to thrive not to survive
we want to be healthy in our
relationships
and we all have the potential to do that
and we're only limited by our choice to
be limited
and i had to learn that very early on
and
i was like a little mouse and a maze it
took me a few
dead ends to to really come to terms and
i'm a student i'm still learning i'm
still learning because the science
is teaching me deeper and deeper aspects
of what it means to be a human
in this in this field that we and you've
interviewed dear friend
the sim the sim harmony there's a dear
dear brother we travel we present
together and i
i really enjoyed the interview you did
with uh with nissan oh
gosh that thank you i again i'm this is
my most fascinated and most
all-consuming
thoughts throughout every day revolve
around the
the work that you guys do i'm curious if
you have a story
that is in the realm of spirituality
that was some kind of an uh an awakening
for you
or um a pivotal
experience in your life a lot of stories
you know what people often ask me danica
is they say how did you make
what they perceive as a quantum leap
they say
they use that term how did you make the
quantum leap from the world of
corporations
uh you know i was a working i was a
problem solver for fortune 500 companies
uh the last one was cisco systems in the
early internet
and they see such a uh
an abyss between that world in the world
of of spirituality
i i guess the first time i was asked a
question i was surprised because for me
there there really was not
a single pivotal experience it was a
logical
progression uh as i began to understand
more
uh it made sense for me to go in this
direction but
i um i think i would have to answer
by saying that the very first experience
was and i don't talk about this very
often but you ask so i will uh
i was electrocuted when i was five years
old
and burned severely burned all my
eyebrows my eyelashes
all all i still have scars with my arms
from it
uh obviously i lived and in those days
the doctor used to come to the house
in in missouri i was in northern
missouri it was in broad daylight now i
remember i had
i had had this jolt
of electricity that shot through my body
and i couldn't talk um i was
not really paralyzed but i for whatever
reason i couldn't speak
my mom had called the doctor i was
waiting for the doctor and while i was
waiting for the doctor in broad daylight
i began
seeing in my room beings surrounding me
that were helping my body to heal from
from the shock
so that experience
at five years old you don't know what to
call that but it
told me it literally shocked me into an
awareness
that i was not alone in the world and
that there are worlds that exist that i
couldn't see
under normal circumstances and
the only way i could see those worlds
was if i had the feeling that i had
through that electrical jolt
and that experience stayed with me and
as i moved through life i learned
that that feeling the power of of my
ability
to have a feeling when i wanted to have
a feeling
to be able to to feel that connection
and communicate if i needed to
communicate with whatever those beings
were
coming from the dysfunctional family um
i uh security and safety
was a big thing and i began studying
martial arts really early in my life
and one of my first martial arts
experiences in the dojo
we had three minutes of meditation and
my instructor he stopped right at three
minutes and i said
i was in meditation and i said can we do
this a little bit longer
i remember he looked at me he said son
he said this is a karate class if you
want meditation you're in the wrong
place
but it taught me then to go seek out
teachers and they're in the u.s
meditation in in the 1960s
was considered to be a cult as as as was
yoga
they didn't think about the way we do
today so i had to seek these things out
and i began
putting all of this together through the
meditations i could have the feeling
that i had when i was younger and i
could
i could commune i was never directed
by other worlds but i felt that i
could commune and when i had questions
about what was right or wrong in my life
i had a place to go
and what i would call what i i
personally would call a very strong soul
compass
and that soul compass was with me all
through the 60s
it was a good it was a good time to have
a soul compass
uh and i was in my first band when i was
14 years old you know we were playing it
was illegal for me i was only 14 and we
were playing in clubs
and my sole compass guided me
to enjoy the music but it guided me into
safety when it came to all the excess
that was happening
with my band mates some of them died
from uh you know from the excess of the
60s so
all this to say wasn't a single
experience it was a series uh
and a progression from early in life of
knowing that there are worlds
that we're simply not taught about in
our society
that i'm related to that are with me
places to go for knowing and for
knowledge
and for comfort and solace and times of
loss
uh and deep hurt which comes from a
dysfunctional alcoholic family
and um and also guided me into
you know music was a powerful refuge for
me as was science those were my my two
for
science nature and music were my forms
of of refuge and that if i'm honest i
would have to say they probably still
are today in different ways
so those fundamental principles followed
me
in uh and i learned to access them in
more adult ways
through through my life but there was
not like a single
transcendental moment where my life made
this quantum leap from
boom one thing to another it was this
progression
long answer to a short question no no
kind of sounds like it happened at five
i mean you've been obviously you don't
collect as much information as you have
and as much awareness as you have
and um would you even say that perhaps
you
you know i definitely would subscribe to
the idea that we come into this world
and we have amnesia of where we came
from and what we are
and i think that there are some that
have
a better better uh trust
or level of just trusting that knowing
or
unknowing in this life and so maybe
there was something that either
came in from the beginning or happened
at five years old
but i think you know having an
experience with beings is a
extremely powerful one and the fact that
you remember it means
that it means something well by the time
the guy the doctor got to the house
uh i didn't really need that i mean
how much detail you want there i mean
they were literally they were they were
very tall they were in the room with me
they were in
one at my feet and my bed
this is the mind blower for me my bed
was in the corner up against the wall
and
one of those beings was standing behind
me and i remember thinking how can
there be somebody standing behind me
there's a wall there you know and that i
mean that's the way the mind works
so uh i think we do
come in with a little bit of a blank
slate
to some degree and what i know is from a
very young age you know
i i love the people this world so much
danica
and and i love this world and i've
always
wanted to be able to contribute in some
way whatever time i have in this world
and as a kid you do that in the way you
know how to do as a kid
and you know as a teenager you know how
to do you do it
you know for me it was through music as
a teenager and
and now it's uh through information and
knowledge to help us
to help there's so much fear i mean the
i believe most people are really good
people that's my experience
and when we go into fear we can become
the most
horrible beings because we will stop at
nothing to feel safe and defend
ourselves from what we fear
and you can try to
impose change upon that fear
it doesn't work and i think we we have
seen that in the world
to me the fundamental key is to
alleviate the fear
and you do that through and we've all
heard this
knowledge is power the better we know
ourselves the less we will fear
a changing world that's going to keep
changing the less we fear
people that we don't know as we
globalize more and
merge cultures together and races
together
and religions that have never been
merged into the same communities before
for some people it's a joyous experience
and for others it
is it's it's scary the better we know
ourselves the less we fear that kind of
change
that it all comes down for me that the
bottom line the better we know ourselves
the less we fear our own power
and as we step into our own power as as
women
as men uh as families as community
societies
nations as a planet as we step
into that power we become very very
different beings we
literally change biologically the
alleviation of the fear
the alleviating of the fear literally
relieves tension and stress at the
genetic level
that allows what's called will to
self-regulation
up regulation of genes and dna we become
stronger we become healthier we live
longer
we become more intuitive we communicate
on deeper levels with ourselves and with
one another
we self-regulate we have these super
immune responses
super resilience to change and it all
comes down to to our ability to embrace
the deep truth
of who we are that's what uses me to get
up in the morning
but uh but but i got to tell you before
i get to that
i listen to a lot of great music before
i ever begin
yeah well obviously obviously it's
working
what do you think about the i think it's
called the hundredth monkey effect
or where essentially there's if enough
of uh and something in a community
learns something there is
um sort of a mysterious spooky things
happening at a distance effect where
everyone picks up the information and
upgrades based
without having seen it or experienced it
i love the way you i love the way you
think danica that's a great question
and do you think that's what we're doing
like is that all that's necessary like
not everybody has to get on board but
they
will as long as one percent or the
hundredth
you know we we are such a diverse
species
ever and that's the beauty everyone
learns differently
it'd be pretty boring if we all learned
at the same time in the same way
but you know and we all see this we see
this in our most intimate relationships
whatever partnership
we have an intimate partnership in life
rarely do people
grow at exactly the same time in exactly
the same direction
often one one will be the explorer
and more open-minded and the other will
be
more content with what has been learned
and discovered in the past
and so the explorer may open new doors
and then the content one
has to choose do i want to grow and go
through these doors with my partner
that principle applies on our planet
this ties into your interview with
nassim
my uh and the sim is in the field
because he and i are working on a course
together and i'm i'm going to be uh
with him in the lab filming very very
quickly so he's been very present with
me through this whole
conversation we met back in the early
1990s we've got a big history
together we met in a little hippie cafe
in taos new mexico before before either
one of us had
ever even done a public program so there
was a time
when the thinking was that it takes a
certain number of people to elevate
the consciousness of a community and a
lot of this was done through the the
brilliant research through the tm
community back in the 1970s and
the formula at that time and i wrote
this in some of my books
was the square root of one percent of a
given population
so you take the population and you take
one percent of that on your calculator
and then you take the square root of
that then that
was believed to tell you the minimum
number of people
needed to elevate the consciousness in
in a group and experiments were done
and what they found was when that number
was reached
during the time that people were in that
meditative state and at
this time it happened they were doing tm
but they've also found this works with
other
other forms of meditation
crime crime statistics dropped emergency
hospital room visits dropped violent
crimes against people
dropped and when when they stopped doing
those things all those things
those statistics reversed but now the
thinking has shifted a little bit
and the thinking now suggests it's less
about the number of people it's not
about the sheer
number it's about the quality of the
consciousness
that a certain number of people can
attain
in this field the field
that knows only coherence
or chaos and this ties into the work
from the institute of heart math
and uh a lot of us nasim and myself and
others have
done a lot of work with them what the
studies now are in princeton university
very strongly showing is that when a
relatively few number of people
can create coherence between their heart
and their brain
through techniques based on laboratory
studies and ancient
traditions of breath focus and
feeling positive uplifting feelings like
gratitude
focused in the heart a slowing of the
breath
to to slow down and
reset the vagus nerve those kinds of
things
a relatively few number of people
achieving
coherence influences
an entire geographic area and the
statistics are very clear about that and
now the sim is showing on the quantum
level why these effects are
so profound because we are connected and
we are
we are more than connected we are
entangled and that entanglement
is happening in ways scientists know
this
in the lab where the problem is is
how to build the bridge between what
they find in the lab in everyday life
so they find these extraordinary
properties of
of fractal patterns and holographic
principles and entanglement on in these
particles in the lab and then they go
home and have dinner with their family
and say
you know it doesn't apply to us it's
just for these particles but we're made
of these particles
right and this this then ties
into the the deep traditions
of the indigenous people of the past the
spiritual principles they didn't know
the science they weren't scientists
but they understood the mechanism they
didn't have to know the math
they understood the mechanism so in a
very real sense
uh a dear dear friend and brother of
mine
dr joe dispenza i know you're familiar
with joe's work
he has said this we present together we
have in the past frequently and i
he says this all the time he says that
science
is the contemporary language of
spirituality
and i i think there's a lot of truth to
that so the science
is spirituality on another level or the
spiritual principles are science on
another level
and i think when we break down we stop
trying to compartmentalize everything
stop trying to keep it in a box you know
i
this is the 36th year that i've led
groups
uh into the andes mountains in southern
peru
and one of the beautiful things of that
culture and other indigenous cultures
is that they never separate science from
art
from everyday life so when
they behold
something that is beautiful to them
whether it's something they
created or it's a sunset
they don't separate that feeling of that
beauty
from science from everyday life what
they know is that in the presence of
that beauty they are changed and we
all are changed in the presence of
beauty when we when we
feel a feeling in the presence of beauty
that's a shift in the chemistry of our
bodies it can upregulate
genes they don't compartmentalize their
world and
we did not used to danica
until the birth of science about 300
years ago
it's only in the last 300 years that we
have attempted
to separate nature from everyday life
and that we have attempted to
compartmentalize
uh the way that we study nature and i'm
a product of this i mean
you know we go to school we study
geology or chemistry or biology or
physics or math and
and you get really good it in your box
so here's a perfect example my first
corporate job i was a geologist a
computer
geologist in the 70s and one of the
first things i saw
happening was that the magnetic fields
of the earth
are are weakening they're in decline and
there's a big curve that started 2
000 years ago interestingly and
and we are at the lowest point and the
strength of the earth's magnetic field
than we have been in 2000 years
when this has happened and it's cyclic
we've seen this happen before
and my question was as a geologist i
said what does that mean to us
what does that mean to to to life
and my geologist friends in their box
they said you know don't ask me
i'm a geologist you need to go ask a
biologist so i asked my biology friends
and they'd say hey
i know about cells and about atp cycles
nobody ever told us about magnetic
fields don't ask me go ask
you know a physicist and that's changing
because we know that nature
doesn't recognize those boxes
we use those we compartmentalize
our relationship to the world so that
we're comfortable studying it
nature doesn't nature's just nature so
now it's it's been said that the 20th
century
was the century of discovery so we
discovered
you know quantum physics and the dead
sea scrolls and the double helix and
and all that now it's said that the 21st
century
is learning to apply those discoveries
and what they mean in our lives and the
only way to do that is to cross
the traditional boundaries that have
separated all those ways of knowing
including science and spirituality
so why judge indigenous wisdom
as less than rather than recognize
these great ways of knowing i think we
owe it to ourselves
to draw upon every every iota of wisdom
that is available to us and to weave it
into a way of knowing that's greater
than anything we've ever had in the past
because we need that
to get through what we're going through
in our world right now it's
it's greater than science can be by
itself science
is the nuts and bolts tells us how
things work
science can't tell us how to apply it
those ancient traditions
they say oh yeah all you got to do is
breathe this way or you know or
you know on a full moon do this thing
but they don't know why it works
we we are the generation we can bridge
these
into a spiritual science if you want to
call it that
and and transcend and for the first time
we have a
we have what we need to give ourselves
the evolutionary edge
to thrive in this great change if we
have the wisdom to embrace it
this feels to me going more spiritual
here but it feels to me like
uh and i'm gonna loop in egypt because i
went there in february
for the first time um like a
union of masculine and feminine because
to me
the masculine energy sort of thinks of
things and the feminine energy is
creation
and so using what we learned in the past
but now merging it
into embodying it and understanding it
and how do we
how do we um create with it and become
and one thing that i came away with that
i was just talking this out with a
friend the other day
and i love talking about these things
because you end up sort of coming to
conclusions out loud live and
in the moment and it was about temples
over there
and i know you've been to egypt and i
know you this is familiar territory for
you
but it's so interesting because in egypt
the temples
like no one could go in the temples
really other than priests and
priestesses
and uh there there's very few allowed in
the regular people that lived there
couldn't and
but it's so beautiful and it's adorned
from you know floor to ceiling with
you know hieroglyphics and pictures and
beautiful things and
i keep thinking what are these temples
for
and you know definitely there was that
feeling of trying to
like for me i felt like it was the
temple within me it was
there to help teach me about the temple
within me but then the other thing that
i thought of that plays into what you
had just said a few minutes ago about
um the resonance of the planet
and it being the lowest now was what i
just said the other days i was like
it feels like these temples were perhaps
where
they would anchor frequencies with
practices
and so it would have that hundredth
monkey effect
for the community because they couldn't
go in so how do they know
other than and how could they thrive
other than someone could
anchor the frequency and so it's
interesting that you just said that
it's not about the quantity but the
quality of that frequency
um so i don't know that's of course just
my intuitive
feeling mind into situations but that's
the feeling i have
yeah well there i think i think you're
right on and i think
i think you're right on and that those
are stepping stones
there were temples dedicated to the
masculine dedicated to the feminine
but then once each of those were
embraced and honored and developed it
was the opportunity to transcend
the difference between masculine
feminine to weave them together
into a wholeness and what i find is a
lot of people
begin that journey and they get stuck
either
in their masculinity or in their
femininity
sometimes even to the point of judging
what
one or the other and the next step in
that journey
is then to weave those into
into a greater knowing and a deeper way
of being because
the truth is we're all masculine and
feminine
to some i mean when you go into the core
of these these principles as
spirit we are masculine and feminine and
i think everyone
pretty much it's paul it's all about
polarities pluses and minuses ones and
zeros
you know boys and girls hot and cold
black and white
but this is so interesting when you come
into this
physical world we have to choose
one of those gets put on the back burner
and one of them
comes to the front burner and we either
we either relinquish some of our
for me some of my femininity to come
into a masculine body but i can still
honor
and preserve my my feminine or
be the other way around for for for you
you came in as a woman and you can honor
that
but there's a masculinity that has
served you in your life
and and we learned to balance those
there's a point where we transcend those
polarities and i think that's what
ultimately with those temples in egypt
i was i led groups for 15 years in into
egypt
uh in the 90s and 2000s and it is an
amazing
beautiful powerful i'd love to talk to
you more about about your experience
there
i did a whole episode on egypt with
nasim because i was like
okay you're we're going to egypt and
then we're going to the quantum
because it's fascinating well it is you
know my so as an engineer
i was uh working in in the corporations
in denver colorado
and my first journey uh out of this
country
happened to be a journey into an
archaeological site and and that was in
egypt and what i saw in the temple walls
in egypt
led me into the andes mountains of
southern peru
and when i met with the indigenous
people there they
directed me into the highlands of
central china
and tibet into the uh the tibetan
traditions
where i learned about the union that
that i'm sharing peru is so feminine i
mean it is so
awesomely beautiful and just such a
powerful feminine energy
that has been preserved there and when i
went into the
the monasteries in in tibet uh
you know high in the himalayas was very
difficult to get there today
unfortunately
was where we began seeing how these
two principles come together in a really
beautiful way
that empowers us in an honoring way
to honor our masculine honor our
feminine honor our humanness and
transcend
the suffering and the hurt and the loss
of what it means to be human in this
world and that that's a very deep
conversation but
i i'm i'm right with you on that i think
that's what
and the interesting thing about egypt is
we now
are discovering that some of the temples
that you saw
probably were built in classical egypt
many of them they now believe were built
way before
classical egypt including the sphanx
geologically we know that that's true
it was built right around the time of
the great flood at the end of the last
ice age which predates those
egyptian traditions that opens up the
whole question
who was here to do that why did they why
did they do it
and what does it mean for us today so
maybe that's
greg and danica part two i don't know oh
god it would be
like an absolute dream to do that part
two
i think for now we've given people a lot
of information a lot of things to think
about
um a lot of beautiful things to think
about i think that it
it is a conversation about a lot of hope
and empowerment
and i appreciate you sharing uh the
science that supports it that again
continues to loop back to sp like
they're we're part of the same hole
i might that's my hope and so maybe you
could just share what your
what your hope hope and dream is for for
the future and then we'll
leave people with something to work on
well you know we we've covered a lot of
ground danica and i appreciate your
your openness and your willingness to do
that you've been very honoring you've
allowed me to speak more than i thought
i want to hear your ideas as well
and we did we covered a lot of ground
and for some people they've heard it
before for some people it may be new
this we're talking about the scientific
way of interpreting and understanding
what already exists and whether we're in
a simulation or not
whether this is a virtual reality or not
we're here
and we're here learning something and i
think the best that we can do
is to be honest truthful
and factual with ourselves when it comes
to who we are and what our potential
is and to to take
that information to become the best
version of ourselves in our lives and
create the best world possible
because we are in this world and
whatever it is that we're here to learn
um i think this is the path to the
learning i know
so many people and you probably do as
well who have had such
painful lives danica that they will make
the
search to understand who they are the
diversion
in their lives and by diverting
from the reality of everyday life
they miss life itself and i i believe
that life is here i
the beauty of this world this is such we
take it for granted
the colors and the sky
and just water and the way water works
and
music and our ability to create these
vibrations that move our soul
you know this is what life's all about
so i just want to invite everyone
i think it's good to entertain deeper
understandings and to use science as a
language but it comes right down to it
it's about you and me and everyday life
uh being the best
the best people we can be and and
finding the joy
that that really makes our soul sing
because i think that's our
compass that's how we know when we're on
the right path
amen amen i think yeah i think i'll
close with that then
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more please click on the subscribe
button